et en pleine pandémie l'or apparaît plus
que jamais comme une valeur refuge le
précieux métal a atteint le record
historique de 1945 dollars l'once l'or 1
plébiscitée par de nombreux
investisseurs étatiques et privées autre
raison son succès en ces temps
difficiles la baisse du dollar cet autre
valeur refuge traditionnelle pour tout
comprendre donc trouvons en direct par
téléphone philippe chalmin économiste et
fondateur du cercle cyclope et bonjour
et merci d'être à des clauses sur un rt
france pourquoi
l'engouement reste t'il aussi fort
autour de l'or de l'or expliquez-nous
vial d'abord on est d'en donner une
raison le fait que le dollar baisse
donc ça veut dire que la valeur de l'or
exprimés en dollars mais traduit dans
d'autres monnaies n'a pas monté d'une
manière aussi forte
la deuxième raison c'est que les taux
d'intérêt sont extrêmement faibles
or voire négatif en nombre de cas or il
faut bien se rendre compte que l'or est
un placement qui ne rapporte rien
lorsque les taux d'intérêt sont élevés à
votre place mondiale s'allient avec de
l'or vous ne gagnez rien mais
l'espérance que son prix puisse monter
enfin il faut se rendre compte qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui par un petit peu un
réflexe de précaution de peur cherche à
investir en or chez poursuivre son
populo on peut imaginer que ne monteront
pas tellement plus loin c'est peut-être
un moment de sortir de la bourse
si vous sortez de la bourse des
liquidités qu'est ce qu'on fait
alors c'est un prince mans sur cet
emplacement tranquille et c'est ainsi
que l'on a vu une augmentation des
investissements notamment de ce qu'on
appelle les ets c'est à dire des fonds
de placement qui aujourd'hui détiennent
plus de 3000 tonnes gorce et jamais
passé est là pour vous situer à la fin
de
l'année dernière il ya deux ans on était
à peine à la moitié alors un engouement
de l'or notamment sur les marchés
asiatiques quand est-ce que vous
l'expliquer traditionnellement les
asiatiques sont de grands consommateurs
d'or les les deux principaux
consommateurs d'autres ce sont des
chiffres alors il est clair que la
demande a été forte ce fait qu'on a des
russes ce site aura à voir paraître
peut-être un petit qu anecdotique on va
avoir une très bonne mousse au hand
quand il ya une bonne leçon
il ya des marquages et lé mariage
traditionnellement en présentant un
moment très important de consommation
d'or en inde est l'un des six tours
l'écart avec le premier ou le deuxième
consommateur mondial d'or on peut
imaginer est la demande aussi plus forte
et puis imaginez que vous êtes un petit
épargnant chinois on savait très bien
que d'une manière ou d'une autre votre
épargne on sera solide à un moment ou à
un autre
alors comme les épargnants français à la
fin du 19ème d'acheter des pièces d'or
des petits la gauche que vous aller
enterrer au pied du troisième show
rigide en jardin alors vous l'évoquiez
qu'elle a été très précisément l'impact
de la crise sanitaire quel est son
impact sur le cours du métal un bain le
cours du métal a quand même considérable
pas augmenter puisque depuis le début de
l'année aurait probablement la matière
ordinaire dont la hausse des prix a été
la plus forte
il a pris presque 30% nous étions étions
à 15 700 dollars l'once en début de
l'année donc avant le co lead et vous
voulez que diront les tadic 940 et alors
on le prochain moment où on parlera de
l'or c'est lorsque il va pour la
première fois qu'à 6 qui sera peut-être
dans la semaine d'ailleurs la barre des
tic des 2000 dollars l'once
vous avez déjà on a déjà des analystes
qui parle
je crois que deutsche bank que la banque
allemande qui a sorti un papier avec des
perspectives à 3-4 ans de leur à 3000
dollars l'once ce qui me paraît
honnêtement totalement déraisonnable et
nous suivrons sa merci beaucoup pour
votre analyse philippe chalmin
économiste fondateur du cercle cyclope 1